what's happening Savages it's Tuesday
the 19th of September this episode of
the check-in is brought to you by liquid
IV get your hydration and check just mix
one stick of liquid IV with some water
and get hydrated two times faster than
with water alone available in awesome
flavors Cherry concour grape my new
favorite is the white peach sugar-free
made with quality ingredients and three
time the electrolytes of your leading
sports drinks adding liquid IV to your
routine is going to be a no-brainer now
listen real people real flavor real
hydrating I've been with these guys
drinking that product for close to four
years now
I love the strawberry the dark cherry
they got a new Cherry but this new white
beef sugar-free forget about it and if
you drink cocktails that's even better
put some rum in this thing here you'll
be floating and stuff but anyway grab
your liquid IV in bulk at nationwide at
Costco
but I'm Gonna Get You 20 off when you go
to liquid.com
did you hear what I just said 20 off
when you go to liquid ib.com use code
Joey at checkout that's 20 off anything
when you shop for better hydration using
promo code Joey at liquid iv.com take a
chance Columbus did it's tremendous
the check-in is also brought to you by
manscape listen if you go into for the
clean shaven look but hate the mess and
hassle of a wet shave listen up guys the
handyman manscapes new electric face
shaver lets you shave up to three days
of growth no water or shaving cream
required who's better than manscape
nobody they got the same solution for
your balls and your [__] you put that
[__] manscape on your nut sack and
your Tip Top Magoo with both the long
hair leveler and full shaver blades no
matter what you look want to look like
the handyman is here to help you and if
you're short on time the five minute
Quick Change feature is a lifesaver with
the rechargeable battery that offers 60
minutes that's right 60 Minutes of run
time with manscape skin safe technology
to help reduce Nicks and cuts you'll
feel more confidence whether you shave
your face your butthole your ears or
your nutsack listen
I'm an old man I still do my [__]
manscape up in fact I got the extra
blade because those white hairs are
tough to cut they're like Paul Bunyan's
mother's tree you know what I'm saying
so if you're a guy in the go never leave
the handyman at home perfect for travel
it's Compact and airplane friendly you
ready for this they're going nuts over
that manscape they're going to give you
20 off that's right 20 off it's the Rosh
Hashanah special free shipping with code
Joey that's 20 off with free shipping at
manscape.com use code Joey let's get
this party started gentlemen
I love your TVs run for your lives it's
over they didn't put you on this planet
just to give up if Uncle Joey could do
it I could [__] rule the world
actually you got to be thinking welcome
back
[Music]
pick that phone up [__]
what's happening Tuesday will you
kidding Tuesday the 19th I'm officially
60 and [__] uh seven months now so
I'm past the 60 and a half
I didn't know you counted half birthdays
now what are you gonna do things are bad
all over how's your week going
my week's going great I had a lot of fun
this weekend in Saratoga that was a
blast thank you to everyone who came out
and said hi
I had a great week and then I I just
it's fun I love I was driving back and I
was just listening to my bets lose which
is Fun the entire way back
and it was just the Green Bay Packers
they just [__] broke my heart
yesterday
you know why are you messing with those
people they're still in the state of
confusion up there pop is gone they
don't know what's going on
let's start back to last Monday night
oh God I feel so bad for them
I felt bad for them but I got to be
honest with you guys I I don't know I'm
a [__] old idiot
do corporations have risk assessment
people
you know that
people have risk I'm just a [__] you
know I don't know nothing about football
I don't know the games but I know the
money they were paying them and uh
what they were expecting from them like
I live here in New Jersey and I go to
the gym in the mornings and they always
have when I ride the bike they have like
sports center on
and every morning it was like are they
going to win the Super Bowl you know it
was like guys the guy's 39
he's got a great defense
he's got a great offense he's got not a
good offensive line
and he's a different [__] Aaron
Rodgers he wears a ponytail now you know
he doesn't eat cheese he's a vegan
that's a different world that's like
you know me with stand up
like if you hire me now for a headlining
gig you know what you're gonna get oh
improvised that's why I don't take the
gigs
he took the gig he took the challenge
and he goes down four plays into it the
Jets first of all did a [__] kiss at
that
it was a Jet fan last night my man Steve
I said they got this you know how the
scientologists give those [__] IQ
tests yeah
they got to go to a jet game with those
[__] people and take IQ tests and go
why do you keep coming here you're in no
danger you dress up with the [__]
silver chain on like a Momo with the
green shirt on I mean they make more on
the shirts and what they do from selling
tickets
I don't understand and I was telling my
friends like I grew up here in the
[__] 70s
and the expectations of your teams was
so much bigger like you know it's even
Belichick and the 70 well the the New
England Patriots didn't have that
dynasty like you know [__] uh the
Jets had like in the late 60s they won
in 69 you know
but all these teams now we just accept
we we go to this [__] Stadium we pay
three bills a ticket
and we got to go home and like you know
you got to get back on the train with
that Jersey they just got killed can you
imagine the giant fans last Sunday night
how to get back on that train with that
giant Sheriff 40 or nothing I like that
thing on fire when I got home shirtless
trouble
I've been saying this since day one
don't sleep on the Jews they're making a
strong comeback
but in reality they never left
I saw a clip today of Ian and Ian
Edwards joke where he's saying he likes
Jews because they named their holidays
after black women and it oh [__] he said
there's like he knows five Rosh Hashanah
doesn't killed me but listen I hate
every New York sports team and maybe
except the Mets
but I respect Jets fans like they've
been [__] I respect them too because
they keep showing up yeah Good's gonna
happen
they keep showing up but now we're
living in a [__] New York City area
where all four teams
a [__] god awful I mean the Giants
played a great game yesterday against
Arizona but they're supposed to kill
Arizona huh Arizona Arizona
is trying to lose they got two they they
fired their backup quarterback and they
they hired two back oh they signed two
backups who had never played it and then
they're doing great do you see that
there was that one where the Arizona
quarterback ran it in and like this like
the guy looks like he has like a health
condition like he has no hair
pulled over the guy like he just killed
him but they ended up coming back the
Giants came back but never have I I was
hearing I don't know I was hearing uh
you know the 80s
and the Giants I think ended up winning
an 87 or something they beat Denver or
somebody or I forget the bills
and uh or New England I have no idea you
know but I know that 86 of when the Mets
won
you know so you have four teams
all of them like okay I don't expect all
of them to be [__] championship teams
but there was something it was always a
ray of Hope in New York New Jersey area
you know and now you got four [__]
bombs the Yankees are what they are
Judges it's a home run they win if you
don't we go home with nothing we're
[__] lint in our pocket you know the
Mets are [__] atrocious I try
watching them you know I'm an honorary
Met fan from my mother but it's so crazy
with sports what we accept now
you look at these teams and
if they don't have a [__] quarterback
I mean we just we're just dead you just
have no [__] team you're just playing
out there and quarterback is the biggest
shortage in the NFL
about the NFL my friend Aaron Rodgers
got 70 million dollars I got two dollars
in my pocket
at least I got my attendance knock on
wood
how was your weekend beautiful
everything was great I uh
I was really I was actually kind of
proud of myself so
I'm so new at the stand-up thing but
I like when I first came back last April
if I was doing a show at like a club I
would pay like I hate walking but I
would Pace I would be so nervous about
remembering like I'd just go over in my
head like from like each joke I wanted
to hit in one order
and then I got a little bit less nervous
about that but if someone like yelled
something out even if I had a joke about
it I wouldn't follow it I would just
kind of like steamroll it
and it I would always be disappointed
because
I felt like it could have been something
like cool and seem a little bit more off
the cuff and seem a little bit more like
in the moment and it happened on The
Late Show Saturday
I have
I don't know if you can relate to this
if you ask me to do 15 minutes I have a
pretty solid 15 now and I have 20 and 25
but it's usually the same order
and Late Show Saturday was the first
time
that
I like followed where the audience like
wanted to go I guess like would I be
and it was like it went great it was
like one of the cool it was like one of
the most fun I've had on stage it was a
small show but it was I don't know I was
just really happy that I went with it
and followed where it was trying to take
me
very interesting when you called me
Saturday night I was watching the
Colorado Colorado State game and you
called me and when you told me that it
made me very excited
because that's a big thing that
a lot of comics don't know what to do do
you address it or do you not address it
if you're in a room work in a room and a
waitress comes in and she's having a
rough night and somebody bangs into it
and she drops three glasses
and the whole audience notices
you have to react to that in some way or
form
I don't want you to go for it if it's a
[__] if there's nothing really there
you know don't put the waitress down
oh yeah there's so many [__]
different things don't put the waitress
down you know I believe in one thing
sometimes somebody says something that's
so [__] stupid that if you join in
It's Gonna ruin the [__] show but
sometimes somebody gives you something
and it's a what do people call that a
Hanging Vine
I've never heard that but that makes
sense it's just something that's there
it's like when you're
when you're going for a triangle in Jiu
Jitsu and he kind of and also you switch
it to an arm bar you saw something there
was a hanging limb somewhere you know
and that's comedy there's always a
hanging limp I always played it off if I
could take it somewhere I address it
sometimes they just throw something
right on your [__] lap
and if you don't address it you feel bad
like you have been
but if you address it and it got
somewhere to go with it
there's an old tape of mine that I was
at the flappers with you one night
uh-huh I got on stage within the two
[__] minutes I gotta say some lady
goes talk about the Jews
[Laughter]
okay in my world let's just use that for
an example if I go
uh uh shut up lady I don't talk about
the Jews you know they've suffered
through you know that's the typical
Hollywood comic I would say it let's
talk about the Jews let's talk about the
[__] Jews obviously she said that
because you're Jewish I had to look real
close because I can't see it
you know Rosh Hashanah says it to me and
[__] and she's black so
I I played with the juju and it won it
it it was good that night
now some nights is going to be bad and
some nights is going to be good and some
nights Lee you're going to have a 45
minute spot and at the third minute of
your show somebody's gonna say something
and you're gonna run with it all the way
to the end of the show you're going to
get off the stage going I can't believe
I didn't say a joke
see that gives me anxiety I have no I
haven't done that I haven't like I have
ad-lib for maybe three minutes like I I
I get I
I don't feel like I'm funny enough yet
to just
go off off the cuff and not do material
when did you start doing that like not
doing material
when I first started comedy I was very
anal like you
and I would not go up there without a
prepared set
and sometimes I would just do like let's
say I had three minutes I'd put like
three jokes
equate them to be one minute a piece but
they'd be 10 seconds a piece right yes
with two [__] minutes of dead air and
I started reaching that's what I call it
reaching you know
and then I got comfortable with comedy
but I came to New York and I made one of
the biggest mistakes that a lot of New
York Comics make is they speak to the
audience
they call it ball busting and for a
while I got involved in that when you
ball bust you're telling me you don't
have material
so when I come right up on stage and I'm
like how you doing I'm Lee Syed what do
you do for a living you know and yes
it's entertaining
for a while
but eventually a club owner is going to
go hey do you have any material you
gotta you can't keep up the rising in my
club
we have something to get really good at
it some guys get really good at it and I
appreciate that but again it's like
going to Vegas and throwing a 50 50 dice
I don't know where my set's gonna go and
that's great when you're in MC in a
feature Act
but when you're a headline unless you're
really good at it
you know they're paying 25 35 45 bucks
to see you
that you know that's great that you
could talk to the audience for 20
minutes but they're there to hear about
you
and your world or your world is
different from their [__] world
do you
do you ever use it as a way to to like
mine new material like if you weren't
headlining like if you were doing a set
at like the ice house or the store but
you never really I don't I don't even
really remember you doing it that much
you would ad-lib yourself but I don't
really remember you talking to the crowd
that much
no because it took me a long it's like
playing basketball and getting a rebound
and dribbling going right back up that's
the worst thing you could do in
basketball as a forward is bring the
ball to the ground and dribble it and
once you start to doing it it's a hard
[__] habit to break and once you
start talking to the audience
it's a very hard habit to bring it's a
habit that I started in 90
two and a half
when I started at the broker as a house
MC and then I came to New York in 93 and
I fueled it with the clubs in New York I
saw it working and I would try to do it
and then when I moved back to Colorado
telling them 93
again I was back into that and then
something happened in 94
then I got to start writing material and
I did but when I got to Seattle I
started doing it again
thank God Seattle was a little bit more
structured
of the city for me and the club managers
spoke to you after you're set
with my situation there's a gentleman
named Carl worman-hoven I just spoke to
him on Facebook the other day
he was the club manager on Mondays and
he would always talk to you a little bit
and he said to me
you don't want to take that habit down
to LA
and what about what was it about him
that like you took his advice because I
would imagine there'd be some Club
managers he'd be like [__] you
he was very knowledgeable by stand up
and just the way he spoke to you
it was never disrespectful in any way a
sense and then I gained respect from him
and I would talk to him after all my set
yeah I would talk to him after all my
sets just
why not on a Monday and Tuesday why not
what
are there any other could I have one
like bad habits that you got into as a
stand-up on stage
speaking to the audience
going on stage with a bottle of alcohol
really okay as a young comic you're
trying to be cool you're trying to those
guys that go up on stage with the Drake
with the [__] straw and they suck on
it or they jiggle the Ice Cube
it's been done already
be original
you know
be original you're gonna go up there
with the drink to get comedy who's got
that drink on first time I go see a cop
who's got that drink on I abandoned the
[__] ship
what's about to do what joke is there
about my drink on right
you know
I I had like a a terrible and I told you
about it like three to six months
I was jumping off early
like sometimes like right as the light
hit I don't know what it was and I
didn't want to and I tried to fight it
but I was so nervous about running the
light that I just
like for like months couldn't help but
get off like two three minutes early
and thankfully it stopped but
when I first became a comic for the
first five or six years
I was speaking in English but I was
talking in Spanish
what does that mean that was I was
talking in English
but I was using my Cuban speed talking
techniques
to get through the jokes because I was
very petrified
we all do that if you told me I had five
minutes I swear to God I would do two
and I'm like I'm good with that
no you're not good with that you got to
go up there and do your material you
give me 15 minutes I'd show up and do
eight and go I'm good
for a long time that was my bad habit
I'm good
no [__] go up there and you owe me
seven [__] minutes
that was a hurdle learning how to slow
it down get the confidence to slow it
down assert yourself and it's something
with your body language where you're
holding your ground but you're not in a
fight
it's the Florida rule hold your ground
whatever some guy with dirty feet hits
you in the head with a [__] bottle
but no the whole thing is [__] once
it and it takes years guys
to hold your your ground technique is
just my confidence you're not getting
around me
you know what I'm saying like you're not
getting around me that's what you're
thinking about but that body language
lets them know that you're running
things
you know a person gets heckled because
he gave three or four people
the
idea that he was self-conscious or
insecure what gives you that idea
so that's when the heckling starts
everybody gets heckled I got heckled
except I didn't a lot of times I let
them throw the Heckle up and you don't
assert you don't you don't you know it's
a stupid Echo
and if you do Heckle back you're gonna
get into an argument and that's not what
your crowd came to see
you winning an argument on stage is not
what your crowd came to see
so what's that
I I it's one of my least favorite things
as like a stand-up fan
is when I go and like the comic is right
away like talking [__] on the audience
like they yelled them that's a young
comic
that's a young comic that thinks that
like myself audiences are different
I used to pre-qualify audiences like you
know look at these guys are old they're
not gonna get that joke
you know now all audiences are the same
you're the one that [__] up this
episode you're the one that [__] up
this set
you know and it's like anything else you
got 10 sets you're gonna bomb off 10 of
them the first couple weeks then after
that you pick up momentum
you do well two of the ten sets and then
three out of ten sets then you bomb for
25 sets and then you destroy for six
sets the whole goal is of getting on
stage so much that you flip the
percentages on
and now I'm not going on now I'm trying
to hold my [__] I would love to bomb
before I got off comedy hold on
there you go
the colostrum is working Jack
what the [__] is colostrum it's breast
milk
okay yeah you drink breast milk now yeah
I got a little chick in the garage I
hang her upside down
[__] got a it's a powder you order
you mix it okay then with the liquid IV
I'm sweating oh I don't miss those farts
no it's a good one it smells pretty
healthy it's got some Katy Perry teen
whatever the [__] kind of baited I don't
know listen what are you bothering me
for I got 600 in me and two from the
afternoon two pieces of [__]
psilocybin mushrooms you know Jesus
Christ
we got New Orleans right now we got uh
tonight we got ourselves a [__] old
school rivalry the Cleveland Browns with
DeShaun Watson and a bunch of masseuses
[Laughter]
going up to Pittsburgh
up there and who the [__] knows man I'm
just happy to see you I had a great
weekend my brother Mike came up from
Delaware
oh he did my brother Mike Ronnie yeah
yeah yeah yeah we came up from Delaware
we hung out Saturday night we uh went
and got a great [__] stake and then
we went up to the Meadowlands to the
racetrack
do they have races
no I go up there to see a [__] play
by the Liz Liza Minnelli yeah they got
races [__] I don't know they can't
they close a lot of those things I'm
gonna be as honest I can with you I
didn't even know the racetrack was
behind me until I was getting ready to
leave
because we were we went to the FanDuel
Center
because my friend was playing on the
third floor his band The Past Masters
can I grew up with this day one great
band
the guy from The Good rats was there
they did take it to Detroit
[__] great it was just it was on a
rooftop
I didn't drink any alcohol
I smoked like 15 joints and I went up
there
I ate a couple mushrooms and I listened
to them I saw a bunch of kids from high
school
bunch of girls from high school it was
great to see him
and everyone even went down there what's
that I'm surprised you even went down
there trust me me too
but I had to get out of the house I had
to go see my man of below it's been too
long you know and it was a perfect night
you know it was perfect it was it's
September in New York City brother San
Gennaro Feast started last Thursday and
I still haven't gone over that because I
want to go in the daytime
but the nights this week are going to be
so [__] beautiful like it rained here
all day but tonight's [__] beautiful
isn't your favorite time in the in New
York in the fall yes yes what about it
because I love I love everything about
New York but like why is the fall your
favorite
because it's just something in the air
the Yankees are in the playoffs no not
this year
[Laughter]
some that's why when 9 11 happened it
hit me so hard because I knew that's the
time of the year that will be in New
York City now they're a little [__]
Fiesta was pouring down by
so I always think of that like I love
this time of year in New York City it's
[__] beautiful it really is beautiful
you know what I'm saying when you get
mugged now you don't feel so bad you get
hit on the street by some guy who hates
Asians you don't feel so bad I got hit
on 52nd Street it was a beautiful day
the sun was out
I landed a puddle full of piss instead
of [__] acid you know whatever oh
thank God have you gotten mugged in New
York
when I was a kid they tried in the Bronx
yeah I got checked I went through a I
went to a play uh a [__] toy store in
the Bronx my mother's dry cleaner was
around the corner
and you know in those days you had to be
careful up in the Bronx
so I had the 20 bills in my sneaker
it smelled like [__] Gorilla Glue and
[__] God knows what else and when I
went to get at the toy store
when they gave me the change the kids
saw me and sure enough I walk out of
there and [__] and I got three little
[__] kids walking behind me and then
I just started running
on Tremont Avenue and I ran I made it to
the dry cleaner before they could get
there filthy little hands on me and then
maybe a year later I tried they tried to
mug me in Central Park for my lunchbox
and then but pretty much when you're
walking around like I I was training I
was trained to walk up there in the 70s
and 80s it was
listen I can tell you a bunch of Lies it
was what it was
how you present yourself on stage how
you stand up that confidence it's the
same thing when you walk in those
streets
so
it's just something that you learn
you know we were talking about last week
about how I don't touch the microphone
and people lose their mind
you know once I found that but it took
years for me to get there I just didn't
pop up on stage and go I'm not going to
touch the microphone it took years of
trial and error and that trial and error
how to touch the mic how to hold you you
ever see an open mic when he pops his
elbow up and you know he's green
on the mic stand I could tell what
you're doing by the way you hold the mic
okay
I you've always told me that I've always
followed your thing I I know you're
going to give me [__] for this have you
ever have you watched any of Mrs maisel
on Amazon no and I'm sure you hate it
the one thing that I could actually like
the show the one thing that upset she
always leaves the mic stand in front of
her
which is like I don't take the mic out
but that's the one thing like everyone
taught me is like if you're gonna take
the mic out you got to move the mic
stand
and she always leaves it in front of her
bugs the [__] out of me you don't like
that show
everybody has
their own thing and when you pull her
aside and you ask her one night like
when you're having coffee Miss maisel
why do you leave the [__] with
microphone there
she'll tell you she'll tell you
something that in her mind she thinks
she's fat
and she [__]
wants to hide behind the mic I mean we
all have the craziest [__] recently
you know everybody has a [__]
different reason on why they do things
Lee what works for me might not work for
you and what works for you might not
work for me
I was talking to Lenny Clark the other
day great Boston comic he was in uh
one of Rodney's specials with Bill Hicks
and dice [__] he was there
you know he was [__] that
and we were talking about something like
I don't know how you're feeling today
but I want you to know something
that for a year I tried to be you
I went out and I put I bought so many
suits on a credit card like I had a
credit card from my divorce right
whatever it was quite forget the store
the guy's name was Bob Schultz
and I would get a suit from him every
week and they would always have to have
a label inside
even if this I would get like a label to
put in there because Lenny Clark when he
did the set that night his jacket opened
and he had a label in that
I love that look on stage I tried it for
a year
and then I had to finally [__] give
back the suits
because it wasn't working for me
but I didn't know it I tried
was it did was it that you didn't feel
comfortable do you think the audience
didn't like not that they didn't believe
that you'd wear a suit audience wasn't
buying it
you can't put a cell cat on a pig
the audience was not [__] buying it
I'm okay with that
they want me to be a hooded sweatshirt
sneakers Adidas jeans that all came to
play later on I used to wear work boots
on stage that don't work I'm not a
construction [__] worker
how do I find this out by trying
I I love I'm very lucky to get to go and
do some shows with Josh Wolf every once
in a while and he told me
that he would do like
experiments for a year like for a year
he sat down on stage
for a year he walked around for a year
he left it in the stand and like
it like so it's to me it's so scary to
test things out like that because I feel
like every time I do a set anywhere I'm
audition like I'm audition like trying
to prove that I belong there
I was thinking about that and I'm sorry
to interrupt you but
let's say you're a feature act let's say
you're an emcee and you go to let's just
make up a club Joey's Steakhouse
and then you go to first year as an MC
then the second year
he really likes and he puts you as a
feature
and then he puts you in there again as a
feature now you're in that 1mc and two
feature times he pretty much likes you
you know what on a Thursday night on a
Wednesday night I don't know why you're
not experimenting
on a Sunday night I don't know why
you're not experimenting they already
like you
you're not going to lose your I get the
first two times you perform there you
want to be like listen nobody wants to
eat a bag of [__] but you gotta you
gotta try your new stuff
and you have to
I really like like listen man I love
stand up and I love being impressed by
stand up I love watching us stand up and
go on
[__]
[__] and saying I could never do that
today
I can't do that today tomorrow maybe in
a year
so I always like to keep it fresh
you know me you've worked with me for
years you know that I like to even move
my material from set to set even if it's
just a material change
because how many [__] people come to
the Early Show and The Late Show
how many [__] times right we show in
Chicago and then the dumb agent would
book me like in Toledo Ohio and it's the
same [__] audience four hours away
now they're telling me I want to see you
in Chicago and I'm like God damn it I
gotta come up with material out of my
ass because I don't give a [__] I don't
give a [__] if it's one day or six
months ago if you see me within a year
I should have new material
well when I come to your town once a
year every 18 months right I should have
a new 45 minutes that should not be a
joke heard
there should not be so many [__]
things
with you
good bro was even before way before I
started stand up when like back when
it's either you or the priest the first
thing that we did the first CD that we
did
everyone else when they're recording a
CD or a special does they might move
around the order a little bit they might
change a word here or there you never
did the same joke
the same way now like it blew my mind
and it would annoy me because I was
trying to edit it between it but like
you I don't even know I to this day I
don't know how you did that
was 20 years Lee
it's 20 years at the end of 20 years if
you don't have a complete grasp on this
art
you didn't work this [__] art okay we
don't have a complete grasp of it
somebody told me that's great that
you're doing comedy 10 years come see me
when you're doing comedy 20 years and I
gotta be honest here they were right I
saw a lot of a lot of improvement
a lot of confidence a lot of remember I
told you that towards the before the
pandemic that last year before the
pandemic I was learning things I was
going on stage and doing something and
going where the [__] did I get that from
not to you or anybody else to myself
and for some reason my mind would take
me to a specific night
where I was in
Montana or Salt Lake City doing a triple
run or doing
some Club who the [__] knows
but I would say wow thank God I did that
that night
because I would have never done it like
it's just crazy you just improve but you
gotta give it a [__] chance
and now with Instagram and Twitter and
all this [__]
it makes the comedian take 50 percent of
his time to work on that when he should
just be focused on the stand-up part of
it for the first five or four years
I would I would because I know I'm just
pissing somebody off on Instagram with
my stupid [__] jokes
right and you know what that was
there's been a lot of talk
and it doesn't even matter about the
specific comic but there's been a lot of
talk about
how much of your act
is coming from truth and how much of it
is made up
do you have any opinion on being able to
you know not fabricate but make things
funny and and change what happened and
let me give you a story here that I
always thought about I was very scared
of always doing this job
I was petrified of doing this gently
and when I would do it I would go [__]
I'm done after tonight
I'm gonna wake up on Monday and there's
going to be a notice that my daughter is
going to be three police officers with
an animal control animal you know
because people would just believe
anything
I had a joke that I did coke with my cat
okay yeah okay
the story of the matter was let's get
down to Basics
one night I came home [__] up on coke
while I was getting coked up there
and then the cat came over to me and
then my anybody who's done cocaine
you're lonely
so I kind of started talking to the cat
you know like what do you think and I
caught myself and I'm going am I [__]
[__]
you got a whole conversation
like I thought that he was talking back
to me like not like with his words like
hey you're a [__] idiot but
telepathically just again in my cocaine
derived mind
in night in 2001 or 2002.
and one night
I was really [__] up
and he came out to sit with me he
wouldn't sit with me he'd sit right here
by the computer and I'd be on the
computer and make him believe I wasn't
coked out but I really was just so the
[__] guy in the circle there that's
watching me wouldn't see me doing coke I
would hide from the little sister from
the camera yeah yeah
and uh
I gave him one night I took a Coke Rock
and he sniffed it like his nose the coke
Rock wasn't the fitness [__] knows so
I put it in the middle and he just like
sniffed it and he went away
that was it that's the true story
what did I turn it into
yeah I love that chemistry for two weeks
I gave him a line
so I turned the three-minute story into
a 25 minute story it was 80 fabricated
but that's what made it funny
everybody knew I wasn't doing cat with
my coke with my cat
but I know eventually it'd be some
[__] that would go dog yeah that
was the most uncomfortable position I've
ever been in and I would talk about
getting paranoid with him that we'd look
out windows together it's something that
happened and I took it to the next level
of fabrication
but everybody knew you know what I'm
saying when I told the hookah story
well I told the hookah story
that was a real story
the Fabrications were exaggerations of
what we were doing
like when we had a fist fight in the car
and we threw punches at each other for
10 minutes that's a lie
that's a play not lie we probably threw
two smacks at each other and everybody
was yelling and screaming because
everybody was nervous a black chick in a
car with a wigs swinging a [__]
straight razor that's never a good
[__] look right there you know what
I'm saying
huh like that word I don't view it as a
lie
it's not a speech it it's a we're trying
to make people laugh a lie to me seems
like
a very negative like we're doing
something to
I don't know I don't view it as a lie
I never told a joke
that was completely fabricated like
I was in the city one day trying to get
some weed
and I you know I was here I was in New
York City I wasn't living here I was
passing through
and I landed in Port Authority and I
checked my bags at like one of those
lockers and I put the A train up to
Harlem and I went looking for weed and I
couldn't find it
and the next thing you know I went to
get the A train back and when I went
downstairs
I saw a crackle I was on the phone with
Josh Wolf
and he'll tell you that the girl came up
to me and she's like for three dollars
in the lighter I'll sucked your dick and
I'm like Josh did you hear that I did a
whole bid on that years later
that you know I
and it was basically for three dollars
in the lighthouse suck your dick and I
go hold on and this is a true story I go
about a dollar in the book of matches
go [__] yourself you fat stinky
[__] I'm like [__] you [__] and
she walked away and she came back and
she goes okay two dollars
I mean it was it was just something that
it was and at the end that what do you
think I'm going through a [__] cave
with it or something like dick you're
crazy for two dollars listen it's like
getting the [__] order house steak
for two dollars you're eating some of
these [__]
possum right
you know what's a two dollar blow job
and a train station gonna be like
purple until next [__] uh whatever
Rosh Hashanah you can't even go to
Grandma's to eat the [__]
because your dick is purple you know
it's a two dollar [__] I was never
gonna go into it I don't think the joke
took me to that she sucked my dick like
we got into an argument
she had a black eye which she did
and that was the truth I said uh well
you smoke crack
and she goes no I fell down or something
I forget what the whole thing was but
that was something that happened
that I turned into something else
and you don't because I don't feel like
I don't
I don't know I don't feel like the most
they had a whole article about someone
and I just don't
I don't know I don't feel like it's a
negative thing I don't feel like we're
we're going out there telling our life
story like it's
it would be crazy like that's
I don't know I don't do you feel like
your life is maybe your life is
funnier than most I just feel like you
know you you take that's what like
learning how to make things funny so
that's why I think storytelling is so
hard I'm not good at it right now right
now it's so hard it's so much different
yeah because yeah you're looking at it
different I did too I didn't discover
storytelling
till
I was nine years into comedy
and I moved to LA and The Vagina
Monologues was big
so I wanted to do something to compete
with it and I called it the the testicle
Testaments
I mean years later you and I revisit
them with stories
the testicle Testament was uh
a story where you found out you had
balls not that you [__] the neighbor not
that you beat up Nikki from the corner a
different situation well hold on we'll
leave it at net I got to give a word out
to my sponsors this week before the
[__] game starts they get their
action in
all right give me two minutes I'll be
right back and now for a word for my
sponsors
what's happening beautiful people Uncle
Joey here to keep you posted up on
DraftKings Sportsbook the NFL action is
in full effect College footballs and for
the fact baseball's in full effect
soccer everybody's in full effect new
customers I'm not going to tell you
again I know you're looking for a home
you're about five dollars and get 200
instantly and bonus bets that's right
200 instantly in bonus bets throw five
down on any of the week's epic matchups
or walk away an instant winner the fun
doesn't stop there either all customers
can take advantage of two new offers
every single game day this September
like I just did with Atlanta what do you
guys think you're dealing with Joey
bananas football is more fun when you're
in on the action just like anything else
anybody can watch porn but if you can
jump in what are you gonna do so
download the app now and sign up with
code Joey new customers bet five dollars
to get 200 instantly in bonus bets only
at DraftKings Sportsbook the official
sports betting partner of the NFL and
official sports betting partner of the
NFL with code Joey in other words when
you were DraftKings the crown is yours
and Uncle Joey's with you too I'm over
here throwing heat with DraftKings so
download the app use code Joey and let's
start having some goddamn [__] gambling
problem call 1-800 Gambler or visit
www.1800
gambler.net if you're in New York call
eight Hope New York or text Hope New
York 467-369
we're back Jack
anyway we've been talking about [__]
uh
telling the story and that's all stand
up is
stand up is whatever you want it to be
it's an art it could be storytelling it
could be one-liners basically it's how
your world collides with the rest of the
world
when I told the story about punching a
[__] nun in the head
the who or whatever think of attacking a
[__] nun that collides with people's
inner that's what you're doing you're
colliding with that inner structure this
[__] went out of nothing when he
was 10 years old what the [__] you know
that's what it is was the nun story of a
lie not at all was an exaggerated at
Parts absolutely
absolutely
that's what makes it funny
right if people don't understand that
who gives a [__]
that's what the problem is with stand up
today you got too many chiefs and not
enough Indians there's too many people
laying claims on people's sets and
they're looking and who the [__] are you
right or even lasted as a [__]
stand-up for a year let me see your
[__] tapes on stand up
you know that's why I joined jujitsu
because I was really pissed off when I
would watch UFC or listen to uh MMA
fighting coverage these people putting
these Fighters down but they've never
done the training I'm horrible at Jiu
Jitsu horrible
but I go because so I understand what
these guys go through
it's always people who want to put this
[__] down that don't go through that at
some level they don't know what it is to
[__] sleep in a bus or you know they
can't understand you got in a Trailways
bus to do a free set two hours away
there's some people that'll never
understand that but they'll dress up
like a [__] pygmy and go to a Raider
game and then jump up and down like a
[__] Google so we all have our
different [__] Force Lee
oh absolutely but that that thing
because you you've always for years have
equated stand up to like fighting like
you can see parallels
I was trying to think I've been watching
a lot of football we've been talking
about football
to me like I always hear like you know
defense wins championships you can't do
the uh we can't be a good team without
defense
is there something like that relates
that to stand up is like is there one
part of stand-up that you think
is like if you don't have this you're
not going to be a good stand-up
well
the number one thing about the stand up
is insight and how he looks at things
the difference on how he could work the
thought
like George Carlin was [__] the king
of that
take a look at something Anthony
Jeselnik
you know there's so many guys that have
an eye uh I was watching some Mitch
Hedberg about a week ago
oh my God
he was talking about something [__]
simple
and he broke it down to the common
denominator when I watched Mitch Hedberg
I realized how lazy we've become a
stand-up comics
because Mitch had Mitch Hedberg wrote a
[__] hell of a joke [__]
Mitch brahedberg wrote a hell of a
[__] joke
and a hell of a bit and just there was
just something about it I just saw one
of his sets on Instagram
maybe a couple days ago Dude I don't
know and it was [__] brilliant
you know and
listen storytelling and I'm the first
one to tell you this storytelling
speaking to the audience
and I know some people are going to
disagree with me but it's
you're going away from the stand-up
routine I was raised that the stand-up
routine as a setup punch line and you
can have that in storytelling how do I
know because I did it in storytelling
but at first I just want you to grasp
set up punchlines
that's the most important thing to grasp
and you know let your mind go wherever
the [__] it goes
you saw Duncan on stage with a [__]
dunk with a dummy
singing [__] wish you were here yeah
Let It Go
who gives a [__] what they think it's
what you [__] think anyway
that's what stand-up is is how your
world collides with everybody else's
[__] world
that's why people say to you I can't
believe you're driving for a [__]
hours to pick up fifty dollars they
don't see it that way you do you see
something to it but then again you don't
see the profit and sell Amway
and telling people hi I have an iron for
sale that guy probably does that for a
living so never
just would stand up listen man I I
wasn't the best writer in the world
I told you last week it was all energy
with me
I knew how to throw my voice I knew how
to command you with my voice I know how
that the word is in command
it's controlled by different levels of
your voice and different pictures you
know these are things that I had to use
you know some people use steroids
you know some people use
this the more sets you do you found out
you find out how you can take advantage
of every situation
from the marijuana use
you know I want you to not smoke dope
and go on stage right now not you you
could do whatever the [__] you want
one to three focus on the stand up
focus on the stand up
and just write I want you to
you know well Joey people say that if I
do current affairs current events the
joke only lasts for a week yeah but you
don't understand you're writing it's an
exercise
it's a [__] great exercise you know
it's funny the other night when you
called me
and we're talking about me about your
set on Saturday night
I thought about
one night when I was at the Improv and I
was showcasing for APA
okay and I was at home all afternoon
just writing notes with no shirt on
smoking cigarettes I was [__] just
trying to write jokes and I'm trying to
write all these [__] Mitch Hedberg
type Jokes which I was never was
but also that's Eyewitness News
and you know in La they give you
Eyewitness News and they go to in
Alhambra and I swear to God these are
the first two stories in La Habra a kid
gets stuck on a sewer and they go to La
Habra and the little fat Mexican kid is
stuck in the ceiling you know and his
parents are begging to come out he's
stuck all you can see is his little head
and the fire department's rubbing butter
on them and pulling them out of there
and he's like ah ah ah I don't know what
happened then they go we're going to
another story in hawaiianville you know
down there uh
the quarterback from the [__] uh
Miami Dolphins where is he from
Hawaii isn't he from Hawaii
they have uh it's where my man God Rest
his soul the quarterback from Colorado
Oceanside I'm sorry
no the guy that died in the in the 90s
that he got the coach's daughter
pregnant
anyway I don't know that one yeah you
guys don't know dick relax [__] uh
so
what we [__] talking about here now
the Edibles are starting to kick in it
was the second news story right so the
second new story would be going live to
Oceanside
and they show a Samoan guy and a Samoan
girl arguing on the street
and she's holding on to a truck right
okay all of a sudden you see the little
someone because the Samoan chick was
bigger than the Simone Guy this is one
of those [__] rare situations they
were dating
and also they show the Simone guy haul
off and punch the Samoan chick in the
face and she basically goes down like a
Weebles wobble bangs ahead and Pops back
up to her feet and that's instant the
guy got in her truck and started taking
off and you see her chasing him down the
street a sandal had broken off and she
had one sandal on her feet were like
mine big dry and ugly with missing
toenails and [__] and she's running
chasing the truck and also you see a
dive into the truck and he speeds up and
she misses oh no a creep and you see it
get like he's like taking off BB talking
about Hawaiian music and donoho and [__]
so I go to this [__] APA thing
an hour later two hours later and I get
up on stage and I thought I had two
great jokes I dropped my first two jokes
and guess what happened
dick that's what happened I didn't get
even a peep
and something made me stop and I said
everybody wants to lose tonight
anybody see that fat little kid get
stuck in the sewer
and I just went with it what the [__]
was he doing to Sewell looking for a
[__] burrito you fat [__] get home do
your homework I just ran with it and
then I went into the ocean side thing I
didn't even know what I was talking to
but it was a seven minute showcase
so I killed five minutes with those two
jokes and then I threw my closer in
voila
but the bad news was APA never signed me
you know what I'm saying so
did they like that like stuff right off
the cuff though the audience liked it
the order I really did I I'll never
forget those two because and after that
I started watching the news but
the Joe sworn any good after that it was
just that particular two stories you
know that's crazy
that's really it's you know what I mean
I really appreciate
I love being your friend but like
it's one of the most frustrating Parts
about comedies I feel like the most
Comics at my level don't have anyone to
talk to about this stuff I love just
being able to throw this stuff out there
and I like that you call me after your
shows while it's still fresh on your
mind
because it gives me a couple days to
think about
an answer for you but I swear to God
when you were telling me that story
that's all I thought about was [__]
uh
the uh the fat Mexican little Mexican
kid that got stuck in the sewer pulled
best I wonder where they are today he's
probably got a bunch of tattoos in place
of where he [__] sewer boy oh he
probably does cameos I was a sewer boy
and so let's talk about football for
this week coming up my friend
so Melissa I got the only bet I've ever
won I beat you in Kansas City Jaguars
I'm [__] I'm happy about that one
congratulations Cox the only one I'm
gonna have all seasons don't get too
crazy remember when you go to DraftKings
you got a [__] profit boost
right now you got the Saints and
Carolina at three a piece
the line is still Cleveland two and a
half over the Steelers who do you like
there in the second game [__] look
I'm gonna go with Cleveland because I
feel like Pittsburgh and I actually have
do I have Pittsburgh uh but I think
Cleveland's gonna be Pittsburgh
I think Cleveland's pretty good they got
that good they got Duke Chubb on defense
okay now Thursday night you got the
Giants against the 49ers in San
Francisco
giant San Francisco's given ten and a
half points to the poor Giants they had
a great game in Arizona what do you like
that Tarzan
I think that one
to me is gonna be saying I think San
Francisco
I mean it's gonna just destroy him I
don't think it's gonna be close but
that's see that the the stuff with the
points there freaks me out like I looked
at that one I'm like 10 plus a lot of
[__] points
I think San Francisco's gonna kill him
but you don't make any money betting
just San Francisco to win
because San Francisco win was like minus
you know
1200 or something last time I don't even
know what but expect the Giants
getting 25 you only win 47. so if you
bet [__] San Francisco and you bet 25
on them you win 47. with this you win
either or if I take the money line on
San Francisco
I win 4.54 cents if they win right
that's nothing with football the thing I
like about DraftKings is the more legs
you add the more money you win
so for a guy like me like last night I
didn't do it yesterday because I was
I did something else yesterday afternoon
I would always bet your Quan to score
he scored two yesterday but I didn't bet
anything so when I bet the Giants I
would usually bet Shaquan
get a profit boost that's what I like
the most tonight you got a 50 profit
boost for any Monday night game
so that means if I opt in
to the profit boost at DraftKings
tonight
and they don't have these all the time
and that's why I tell people you got to
jump on top of these [__] so
before was
now if I what the [__] where's my draft
posted
but those things they got me last night
with that I had Tyree kill 75 yards or
more and they gave me like a 100 profit
boost and he had 40 yards the only good
thing the Patriots did last night
okay so with the profit boost
I make 48 dollars if I went Pittsburgh
and with the profit boost
oh hold on this is a good profit boost
I get
57.60 so it just went up on a 25 bet so
if I take Cleveland Browns minus two and
a half I get a 50 profit boost maximum
100 wager
How Are You Gonna Act if your [__]
rims don't
aren't clean anyway you got the Giants
in San Francisco
but you also got Buffalo at Washington
plus six and a half you got Jacksonville
playing the Houston Texans in
Jacksonville
yeah that one
there's a lot of like one-sided ones
next week I think
yeah you got Miami playing the Broncos
in Miami the first home game of the
season given six and a half that'll
probably go up to seven this is a
phenomenal game next week Indianapolis
Colts against the Baltimore Ravens in
Baltimore Baltimore giving seven and a
half
Detroit's playing Atlanta in Detroit
giving three and a half I'm gonna go
with Detroit on that game
for the Colts in the Baltimore see that
one I think Baltimore should win but
when I when I checked before the over
under was 44. yeah yeah and I think it's
gonna go oh because I look so this is
when I and I don't know if I'm
overthinking it the Colts have allowed
31 and 20 points yeah you're
overthinking it you don't think it's
gonna be over 44. you don't work for it
yeah but let the line it's only Monday
let the line breathe for a couple days
let's see where it goes before you start
making selections on the open up because
that [__] could shift three points
something that happened down the three
points
so yeah listen man Ravens could throw up
some points
and Indianapolis Colts got a new
quarterback this is pointing at it over
and under you're like well we have
shouldn't it go over
you've never seen the Boogie with a
part-time job next New England Patriots
Cuts in HorrorLand day
the Jets are look at this New England's
given three points we have because
and I feel so bad for whatever his name
is the new the Jets quarterback but we
we just destroy him I think we're gonna
win this game but it's let's if we if we
lose to the Jets
if the Patriots lose to the Jets
Bill Bell injection have to retire that
would be
embarrassing I was watching him last
night
and I'm like with all the great things
he's done
it's time for somebody to tap him on the
shoulder and say it's time to go You've
Won I don't know how many rings you've
done so many great things
you just you got a team that it's gonna
you you don't have enough time to turn
them around no he's got to get start off
[__] new again with these guys he's
too old he's done what he had to do he
has to he has nothing to prove to the
people of Boston or New England or
anybody
so
who gives a [__]
anyway
you got the Chargers playing the
Minnesota Vikings I don't know I don't
like these two teams
Cleveland Browns are playing the Titans
minus four let's see what happens
tonight
Arizona's playing the Cowboys in Arizona
's plus 12 points Kansas City's playing
Chicago at home Kansas City's minus the
13. I like that bet
uh Pittsburgh is giving one to the
Raiders
and next Monday night you got
what is this [__] two [__] games
again
these people getting [__] creepy
Philadelphia's Tampa Bay and the Rams
against Cincinnati
that's a great game in Cincinnati I
think my boy is hurt
yeah huh
Joe borrow his heart yeah
and Major League I've been doing okay
this is what I like about him man let me
see the Mets and Marlins are tied up
Cincinnati is winning you know I got
them tonight with the profit boost and I
also got Philadelphia over Atlanta and
Atlanta it's the third inning if you
know anything about Atlanta they come
back [__] every game you bet that
money line right now Atlanta is losing
by two if you put a 25 and now they're
not taking [__] money line because I
decided to hit the [__] board we
think I'm Lisa yeah there you go boom so
if I take the money line right now for
Atlanta
if I bet 25 hours on the Atlanta
Braves right now in the third inning
you get back 77.50
are they losing
yeah
but in the third
they're losing the Philadelphia they got
Phillies pitching a great guy tonight
forget what his [__] name is it don't
matter and uh
but that's Monday night I like looking
at baseball because
everybody's betting football
listen right it doesn't mean you're a
big shot if you know who's going to win
New Orleans or Carolina it doesn't make
you a big shot if you know who's going
to win uh Cleveland Pittsburgh you know
what makes your winch a big shot that
you win money whether it's 25 or ten
dollars so tonight all the focus in
sports is on Monday Night Football
a guy like you a slick little hustler
boom you know what I'm saying [__]
get a 50 boost on any live MLB bet
tonight what I'm gonna do is this right
now right in front of you [__]
I'm gonna opt into that and I'm actually
um
and I'm actually gonna put
come on [__] I'm actually gonna
put 25 in Atlanta bonus available
the bonus is uh
MLB 50 live bonus maximum hundred dollar
wager 50 profit boost so now if I take
the small if I take Atlanta the money
line they win I put 25 in to win 11 15.
Jesus
you know guys this is not to be popular
at the bar and tell your friends who
what if you're gonna bet you're doing it
to win [__] money whether it's and
you're trying to double your investment
so if I put 25 down 47 is not acceptable
it's not acceptable I got Chinese lunch
I got [__] I got bills to pay I got
gas for my [__] car
get up
so
what's your favorite pick of the week
that tarzania
if you had
something I think the Chargers are going
to beat Minnesota
I think the Chargers are going to beat
Minnesota I think that I have a couple
unders I think the New England versus
the Jets is going to go under 37. that's
what I saw it at right now I understand
you want to wait on it but I think the
both offenses suck and we both have good
defenses
and the other one I had was the the
Colts in Baltimore over 44.
yeah I like that too I like the Ravens
too kid
yeah the Ravens Lamar Jackson's great
and I like the Colts and I like their
new quarterback but he got he got they
pulled him out of the game last week
because he had a concussion
so they might have like their backup in
so I don't know that those are my those
are the because I the other one and you
said it today with saquon
the the anytime touchdown ramondre
Stevenson I don't think he has a
touchdown yet this year if he does it's
not
for the Patriots because I think we're
gonna I think the Patriots are gonna
beat the Jets if if we don't it's a it's
an embarrassment what's with the Wii
getting out there this weekend doing
[__] practices with them
yeah you know I I have to listen they I
would help them out at this point that's
how bad we've been
what do you got this week what kind of
shows you got this Thursday I'll be at
the The Loft in Chicopee it's a good
it's it's a good Jewish deal we have for
20 bucks you get a buffet and a comedian
thank you
it changes every week sometimes it's
chicken sometimes it's steak they got
veggies it's not it's a fun deal mystery
meat no no I I I've never knock on wood
because I always I always eat it I have
never gotten sick it's a it's I love
going to places where there's not much
else to do which is exactly what
Chicopee is
and they're they're so much fun
and then next week
Friday and Saturday this week I don't
have anything right now Friday Thursday
through Saturday next week I'm in Omaha
with Josh Wolf you know right now you're
doing the best thing you can with
stand-up comedy you're living on your
rules on your terms
you've got a day job you're not worried
about [__] headshots like they were
in La already
you're not worried about your resume you
know where all you're worried about is
getting on stage every night
and this is
the best time of your life I think
for me if I have to look back that was
the best time in my life 91 to 95
[__] getting in a car with four of
your friends and even in Seattle Seattle
was where I really learned
the I was a true open micro up there
that became a feature act up there not
in whatever when I went up there I was I
was already kind of featuring 25 minutes
but going up there that camaraderie I
had with Brody and Josh and tana Manu
and Mitch Hedberg and Stan oh it was you
I'll never have I never had that again
so when you're driving to these gigs and
you're thinking [__] I can't wait
take your time
I I I I I've heard other people say
you've said it before
I have a really and it's not even just
stand up in life I have a hard time
being patient and it's
I'm really trying I'm really trying to
enjoy it
but you think I was patient my friend no
probably not I'm telling you
you have uh no disrespect you have
Jewish neurosicisms whatever those
[__] things on the Roses whatever it
is where you go crazy like Felix
[Laughter]
so uh
you don't need it
I mean with you I get it with me I'm not
gonna lie to you it was we wanted
everything to be perfect
you know you want everything to be
perfect but that's why it's stand-up
comedy it's not going to be perfect a
waitress is gonna drop a glass
uh audience member is gonna puke
uh audience member is going to pass out
on Edibles we've seen that a couple of
yeah the last 10 years you and I we
start you know you experienced a lot of
different audiences don't ever blame it
on the audience
blame it on yourself
you tried to be how many nights have you
got there with too much ego
and you know how many nights I would
kill on Tampa
I would kill at the Miami Improv for a
whole weekend I was a feature ACT people
come up to me light cigarettes from me
give me cocaine and that Sunday when I
landed in Miami when I landed in L.A I
couldn't wait to go down to the comedy
sport to talk [__] on how I slayed Miami
and and then I'm going to go up there
and do a spot and Lead You know that
nine out of 10 times I would die the
slowest death of all [__] time
did you know that and that's the god
honest [__] truth I would just die on
stage
and would it just deflate you or what do
you think like [__] them or like what
would you think oh what the [__] I just
did the same set I did the last five
[__] nights and it killed every night
now at The Comedy Store I died you know
what the answer was I walked in there
with too many big balls
I had to humble myself so since I didn't
humble myself the comedy humbled me for
me
and you get that from time to time you
know what that does to you but all these
little things are just all a part of the
[__] Journey
and you turn into one big scab I'm just
one big scab look at my face I got scabs
got scabs on my elbows scabs on my knees
I got scabs on my ball sack but most
importantly I got all the scabs from
[__] getting beat up and stand up and
one day your body just becomes a [__]
scab and now they can't do nothing to
you the infection's gone you're done now
I gotta go move forward
right or wrong the infection's gone I
got a thick scab over the cut
you know that's what we are as a comic
you're just going to become one large
[__] scab
of pain you're not funny enough you're
not tall enough you're too old you're
too young you know the reason it's got
got nothing to do with your talent
think about that you saw it
they'll come to you and go well you're
not funny because you're fat we don't
think fat people are funny okay
and now you got to go home and eat a
sandwich and come back even [__]
stronger and like that little Mom and
Pop shop on fire
yeah it's
and I appreciate it and I know I I know
you're right but it's you're right I
want everything not only do I want to be
perfect
but I want
I I just sit sometimes on like the drive
home from shows I just imagine what it's
gonna be like
I know this doesn't mean anything but to
have someone booking shows for me to
have like just someone who can call me
and have like a a full calendar like
next week you're 10 years away I know I
am and that kills me that's it and I'm
not even talking about headlines and
guess what when you have that person
you're still gonna have to book your own
gigs
how's that for you because they're going
to call you with some crazy office and
then you got to tame them off the roof
and go whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
this is where [__] Lee Syed is doing
so don't worry about that right now just
worry about [__] writing having a
great time and do something I never did
when I walked into a comedy club
what's that something I never did walk
in
stop at the door I don't give a [__] if
they look at you or not
look around the room and this is for you
and every other young comic that's
getting into comedy or in the three year
mark or the four year mark or even the
five to six year mark I'm gonna give you
the best advice that nobody ever gave me
I just did it myself and when I found
out about this
it changed everything you're gonna walk
into a comedy club close the door like a
gentleman look some people are looking
you're gonna wave but before you bust
that next move
you know how you you stand there and you
look and you go hey Timmy hey Marty hey
Johnny hey Joey when you see that person
before you move
I Want You to Breathe
take a pause and go no matter what
happens tonight
no matter what happens tonight it
doesn't matter because at the end
they're all going to suck my dick
and that's the attitude
whether you have a great set whether you
got a standing ovation whether you bomb
all you know is whatever happens tonight
you'll be here tomorrow night too and
the night after that and no matter what
happens all these [__] that are
looking to put you down oh he did a
stolen job you know there's all I heard
I heard uh Ryan Philippe do that joke
and [__] whatever
after all that [__] and all the
years you're not an amateur somebody
gave you five dollars you can't enter
the contest
it's that you're scaring people
and all that [__] happens is that you're
starting to scare people you're going
outside the normal Circle
and that's a complete education that
we'll get to another time but from now
on do what I didn't do
what I did years later and I wish I
would have done it from day one Walk In
Breathe Jim Morrison take a look around
say which way the wind blow
with a little girl with no forget it
just take a look around and which way
the wind blow notice wherever you have
to meet hey how are you and right there
in your mind before your as your body
stepping forward that motion that we do
right there
no matter what happens tonight doesn't
matter
because eventually all these
[__] gonna be sucking my dick
I'll see you next week but we'll talk
during the week I love you buddy I love
you buddy and now for a word for my
sponsors stay black
back to church
[Music]
get your hydration and check just mix
one stick of liquid IV with some water
and get hydrated two times faster than
with water alone available in awesome
flavors Cherry concour grape my new
favorite is the white peach sugar-free
made with quality ingredients and three
time the electrolytes of your leading
sports drinks adding liquid IV to your
routine is going to be a no-brainer now
listen real people real flavor real
hydrating I've been with these guys
drinking that product for close to four
years now
I love the strawberry the dark cherry
they got a new Cherry but this new white
beef sugar-free forget about it and if
you drink cocktails that's even better
put some rum in this thing here you'll
be floating and stuff but anyway grab
your liquid IV in bulk at nationwide at
Costco
but I'm Gonna Get You 20 off when you go
to liquid iv.com
did you hear what I just said 20 off
when you go to liquid ib.com use code
Joey at checkout that's 20 off anything
when you shop for better hydration using
promo code Joey at liquid iv.com take a
chance Columbus did it's tremendous
the check-in is also brought to you by
manscape listen if you go into for the
clean shaven look but hate the mess and
hassle of a wet shave listen up guys the
handyman manscapes new electric face
chamber lets you shave up to three days
of growth no water or shaving cream
required who's better than manscape
nobody they got the same solution for
your balls and your [__] you put that
[__] manscape on your nut sack and
your Tip Top Magoo with both the long
hair leveler and full shaver blades no
matter what you look want to look like
the handyman is here to help you and if
you're short on time the five minute
Quick Change feature is a lifesaver with
the rechargeable battery that offers 60
minutes that's right 60 Minutes of run
time with manscape skin safe technology
to help reduce Nicks and cuts you'll
feel more confidence whether you shave
your face your butthole your ears or
your nut sack listen
I'm an old man I still do my [__]
manscape up in fact I got the extra
blade because those white hairs are
tough to cut they're like Paul Bunyan's
mother's tree you know what I'm saying
so if you're a guy in the go never leave
the handyman at home perfect for travel
it's Compact and airplane friendly you
ready for this they're going nuts over
that manscape they're going to give you
20 off that's right 20 off it's the Rosh
Hashanah special free shipping with code
Joey that's 20 off with free shipping at
manscape.com use code Joey